this might be the funniest clip I've
ever seen in my life many of you have
expressed deep anger and disappointment
many of you are upset that someone who
attempted to destroy our democracy was
invited to sit on the stage in front of
a crowd of Republican voters to answer
questions and predictably continue to
spew lie after lie after lie and I get
it it was disturbing as good a job as
Galen Collins did trying to fact check
him it is impossible to fact check fully
because he lies so shamelessly you have
every right to be outraged today and
angry never watched this network again
do you think staying in your Silo and
only listening to people you agree with
is going to make that person go away
we're sorry you can turn off CNN it was
terrible we had the president very
popular president come on he's going to
run for president again half the country
likes him what makes the clip so funny
is just the seriousness
many of you
for last night it was
former president saying that we need a
better economy